this way you can google it up and it'll
show my name
and it'll tell you about the past robbie
for some reason
i never understood this they called me
the white bag bandit
and i thought back on i never had a
white bag with me
and i said to this day i honestly don't
know why i was called the white bag
bandit
when was the last time you robbed a bank
2015.
20 000 not that long ago yeah um
how'd this start
it's by accident i understand you what
happened when i was living in berkeley
california
i was strung out on heroin
with my girlfriend and i had a friend
named
a friend named john his name was john
sue and he was a burglar a white guy he
was a burglar i met this guy one night
about three o'clock in the morning i
thought he was homosexual honest got you
because he wade pulled up but he just
got out the joint
we saw him so one day where i lived in
berkeley we're going back to my my
apartment and he said hey i got to stop
and do something real fast so he went to
a bank you know this bank is right on
the corner
half a block from where i lived at he
went up there with a note he robbed the
teller i didn't even know it's honest
got truth i had no idea that i was even
involved in this robbery
10 10 15 days later i'm sitting in an
apartment knock at the door
two cops there and my nickname was john
boy and berkeley i had a nickname i was
known for drugs and stuff like that and
cops says i'm john boy he's uh
you're under arrest i go forward he says
bank robbery i go what the [ __ ] you tell
my bank robber
the only thing that saved me they never
arrested him
and i never approached anyone inside the
bank or anything like that i was just
standing there and they explained to me
what happened so i seen him afterwards
what the [ __ ] how come you didn't tell
me at least give me some of the money
[ __ ]
but it wasn't a whole lot of money back
in and what he did took a note and he
robbed him
and about two three months later me and
my girl split up i was in san francisco
one day just walking around dead broke
sick i needed some drugs i walked into a
bank with a no i wrote a note this is a
robbery i have a gun
and the talent i never forget that she
gave me 1600
right i agree to me it was like a
million dollars i grabbed it ran out and
it was from then on
first time i got arrested i robbed 33
banks in 30 days
didn't get caught no no no i got caught
on the flu i got caught in oakland
california and the way i got caught i
was in a taxi cab
we're going down the street one way the
cop car was coming this way man i had
this girl julie in the cab with me
they caught
see me they knew me
and that's how i got arrested for it i
know i've never once been arrested
inside of a bank
coming out of a bank um
it's a closely ever came in i've never
gotten arrested the same day
i've robbed the bank
you know i'm saying i've never i've
always gotten away it's never been the
exact same day i've always been
first time i got honest got you i was
out
three
three weeks i think it was
and i robbed 21 more banks
i just got about 21 more banks
got arrested this was in 1986.
got arrested i did 13 year
you know i got a 13-year sentence then i
did nine years on that sentence
got out
was out about another six months
and we robbed
another
i think they said it was another
approximately 30 banks or something
what's the secret to arriving at bank
it's got to be a lot of adrenaline
i turned into a different person
honestly like what happened everyone
tells me that um
i get like geeked up before i go in it's
like it's another high and it takes me
i can come out like after being get high
whatever it still takes me
a couple hours i can actually calm down
i'm just just come down because i get
this this mentality in my head that like
once i go in there i'm coming out with
money
period i'm not gonna
take no for an answer you're gonna give
me some money and i've never
i'm trying to honest guy have i ever had
to load it down with me
yeah a couple times i had that well i
had a gun with me that was actually
loaded but the majority i've never had a
gun with me
i've never had a weapon what's the
what's the fuel behind deciding to rob a
bank is it a drug addiction yeah
it might you know if the drug addiction
but then it got to the point where
it wasn't even a drug addiction it got
it became
addicting itself the adrenaline behind
it because
i had a friend
and he used to wake me up
and we're doing together and we were rob
banks
and we didn't even need the money
that makes anything you're just doing it
for that
we get up he come get me like nine ten
o'clock in the morning
let me go hit a bank come back and i'll
go back to whatever motel we're staying
and go back to sleep
and wouldn't even come to count the
money later on a day or something like
that just it just got to be
like i've never had a job in my life i
understand i've never had honest
i've never had a job in my life i'm 62
years old i'll be 63 in december
and i've been majoring in my life in
prison
so yeah like out here in the streets no
i've never worked and it's been
and people meet me and they'd be
surprised
at my lifestyle because they said i
don't look like that type i'm not
and just i don't know how do you how did
you grow up
tell me about your family um mother and
father okay they separated when i was
maybe 12 years old but my father was
always part of it i would see him every
day
um
i was the last child at home i was a
baby of the family i was the last one so
i was spoiled rotten
and what happened i grew up right here
in los angeles and um over by venice in
fairfax that area over there
and
gang banging this is like in the 70s
game thing just
started becoming irrelevant
so what they did they decided to send me
to san diego live with my sister older
sister live with her and her family
maybe i'd keep me away from me got worse
my sister was a she passed away but she
was a devout jehovah witness
and i remember i got some job at school
one time
and i was spinning they put me in this
jehovah's witness
it's like a group home
right and the guy takes off a belly
somewhere he's gonna whoop me or
something
and i took off i ran away from there i
came back to los angeles my father said
okay he'll send me up north to oakland
live with my grandmother trying to keep
me away from los angeles the gangbanger
and all that and i go up north
i don't know if you you know know about
berkeley california i go to berkeley one
day telegraph avenue
this is one of the while this hit these
uh flower child and all that and fell in
love with it
and from then on it was i was like i
think i was like 16 at this time
and from then on my life went straight
downhill
straight down there is that where drugs
came into the picture uh it started for
lsd
well marijuana lsd
and i had a heroin connection you're
like
i had a nickname i was the only black
guy in this whole in a whole little
group my nickname was john boy just like
off the wall this that was a [ __ ] i was
the youngest in a group and i used to go
buy heroin for this guy
and they would pay me money so one day i
went bought some i said let me try this
and he gave me a tiny bit i just you
know he shot me up i tried it hated it i
got sick as a dog throwing up so the
next day i said it couldn't have been
that bad let me i did it one more time
and fell in love with it
i just got heroin
destroyed my life well i destroyed it
myself but
drugs played to me and you know in
school
i was a great uh a straight-a student
honest guy
when i was in
fifth and sixth grade well now it's
martin luther king but it was it was
santa barbara elementary school back
then on santa barbara and western i went
that's where i went to elementary school
i was a tutor they had me
you know i was children i was tutoring
kids in junior high school and i was
still in elementary school
you know reading writing arithmetic was
my thing and um
but then
drugs just destroyed like everything and
right now it's still enjoying me because
i'm on the house with everyone in my
family
you know
i'm in contact with no one
and
well i was in contact with my brother
but
that's kind of shaky too right now your
drug now is fentanyl or heroin
both
both and fentanyl is um
that's the worst thing ever
honestly that's the worst thing they
ever came up with it sounds stupid me
saying that because i use it but i'm
just being
honest about it it's it's
nld
since honest got this year along since
january this year i loaded five times
and one time they said that i actually
they thought i was dead i would be right
here in um
on ninth and um
right across from rouse i think that's
hope grant park yeah right there in the
park
and i woke up in the ambulance and uh
you seem sensible enough to understand
how dangerous it is and how destructive
it is but it's not as easy to just quit
right that's the problem i understand
how
is they i know it's not i know i'm
killing myself but i just can't
stop
honestly i just
i go through these periods where like
i hate it but i love it
if it makes any sense
if that makes any sense
you know a person would have to actually
go through it to understand what i'm
saying to like where you're doing
something that you know is no good for
you
but you do it anyway but you do it
anyway
you've been in love before excuse me
have you been in love before oh yes oh
yeah
um
my first love was
[Music]
i ruined her life well i said we were in
each other's life because uh she's more
she's more of a heroin addict than i was
and um we had a son and
never saw him
but i saw him once
when he was born and we hadn't even
doubted that we adopted him out and
she was really my first and only love
she was um
we had a love-hate relationship
to like we would be together
split up but
we're always together no matter who i
was with she was always a part i was she
was always in the picture and i was
always in the picture with her and stuff
like that
and um
i heard from her
right before i got her first and last
time in 2015 i heard she other blues i
don't know where it came from she wrote
me a letter i was in prison i don't know
how she found me or what
and she wrote me a letter since she was
in san francisco and i never bothered to
look it up because
at the time when i got out of prison i
had this big
in my head that i was going to
straighten up do everything right
i'm not going to mess with no drugs no
nothing i come home
and
my father was fighting cancer at the
time and this is how the bank robberies
happen the last one was out there and he
was at um
he was at um
veterans hospital in santa monica and
every day i was in a halfway house i
just got home from prison and i would
take a bus
you'll see him at the hospital every day
i go to western va hospital to see him
then we go down the bus goes down
wilshire
and one day i don't honestly got you i'm
looking out the window and i see this
bank on the corner
and i got off the bus
when there was a no rob didn't have a
car
a driver nothing no way to figure out
how to
get out of beverly hills after i robbed
his bank
and i went inside robbed the bank came
outside it was a cap sitting outside
i got in the cab
went to veteran hospital i did i went to
hospital see my father
and i'm counting his money in his
hospital room you make it sound like
he's just stopping to buy a pack of
cigarettes at the time that's what
to this day
till this day i don't know what made me
do that
honestly i do not know what made me get
off that bus
do you have a self-destructive street
yeah i think i do
matter of fact it's not i think i know i
do because the bank robberies the drug
use um
i want this person to destroy everything
good
i do for some reason it's just like
once
i'm doing something and it's
really good i do something
to destroy just sabotage yourself every
time every time oh
i'll meet a person something like a girl
or whatever good i'll steal from
something i'll do something stupid is it
not believing you deserve the good
fortune
that's come your way or
i can't answer that because i never
really thought about it as far as not
deserving anything i've never really had
anything
that i've earned
if it makes sense everything i've ever
had in my life too i've taken
and
it gets to the point where like
people start believing in me like you
know i can do good i can do this i can
do that and then i have to do something
just to show them how i tricked you
and i don't know why i do that and then
you know i always regret it later but at
the time i don't think
and all i know is okay i'm broke i need
some money i want to go get high
all right i don't think about no
repercussions no
nothing all i think about is the here
and now and later on
and i'm i'm really messed up in the head
because i have no um
sympathy button i've never felt bad
about anything and i don't understand
why i've never felt bad about anything i
still know anyone i ever stole from
do you believe in karma
yeah
i really do i really really and
i mean i had a dog we named that dog
karma i don't scout you we had a dog i
named her carmen but karma to me was
like
anything something good happened for me
i blamed him on karma but it was bad i
blamed it on bad luck
if it makes any sense you know but
and i
to me like we used to say karma's like
say i go out and rob a bank and i get a
bunch of money
you know your addict with me i'll go out
and get you high
i'm showing a good karma now because i'm
spending now that that that that's
that's that was our definition of karma
because i'm going to get you and some a
bunch of other people that's good karma
to me because
you know then when something bad happens
and something good comes back oh that's
that good karma coming back from me
looking out for you if you had your life
to live all over again what would you
have done differently stating school
stayed in school i dropped out of school
when i was in the ninth grade
guys stayed in school and
do you wish you'd watch the straighter
path
oh
that person most definitely
i tried um
one other thing like i was 18 years old
and
18 or 19
and i wouldn't join an army
it's the truth this is crazy i went and
joined i got
to the point where i went i got sworn
into everything the night was i was in
oakland california was supposed to leave
that morning
i was supposed to be down to oakland
nations building at six o'clock that
morning i was going to um
south carolina fort jackson south
carolina
basically from grill and i got arrested
that night
the same night absolutely i got arrested
for some bs and um the army turned me
down after that and from then on it was
if i think if i would have went to the
army it would have been a whole lot
different
do you have friends
i have associates
yeah honestly because i can't say it's
like out here on the streets
no friends
what are you afraid of
myself
honestly myself because
that's when you asked me that because i
was telling a guy the other night i
began to argue with this guy and i had
to tell this guy like see i don't know
what you would do
an altercation i don't know how you
would react but i know my reaction
and so i'm more afraid of what i would
do
than what someone else would do to me if
it makes any sense because i
i know my limits and
i have none
yeah um
i just have a t-shirt that says today
every day's a fine day to die
and that's a hell of a way you go
through life thinking a little dumb [ __ ]
like that you know i mean you know
do you think this
this trait is something you inherited
from your family or is it just something
i can't say that because i'm one of my
families just like this i'm the only one
you're treated in a way that yeah i'm
the only one in my family
with the drug problem everything
everyone else in my family
is my sister she passed away from cancer
but she worked for
the university of san diego she was an
oceanography department i have my oldest
brother he lives in thailand right now
he retired he lived in seattle he was
basically the black sheep of the family
it's crazy because my oldest brother won
in thailand
he's 12 years older than i am but we're
born on the same day
both was our birthday december 4th and
they tried no they did and i understand
why they do what they do now you know
but i used to blame them for
not giving me money
and when i came home from prison i had
some money that supposedly
well
my mother left some money for us and
i owed the feds a lot of money for the
bank blah blah and i couldn't have
anything in my name so what we did they
left it to my brother and they were
supposed to give it to me and when i
come home they they were giving it to me
at first
then i started using again
and
they cut my money off and so that that
was my excuse
go out and start doing everything again
you know that was my excuse and
this is i've been out now two years
honestly i've been out
june may two years this is a long never
been out on the streets in my life
without going to jail
and
i haven't thought about robbing or
anything like that i'm actually scared
now of going back to jail
and i guess i'll be 63 years old in
december and
it's a hell of a time i want to start
living
you know is there a chance you could
just
turn the corner and rob a bank and end
up yeah it could happen in china
honestly because i have is there like an
angel on your shoulder and a devil in
the other yeah and there's been days
like where
i say uh
if
something doesn't happen by certain
times blah blah blah i'm go out and rob
something
and i haven't done it but i'm afraid
that i will honestly because
what stops you from doing something
honest
i've tried honestly god everything like
every time
my patience for one
thing rob in the bank is fast money yes
and what i mean by my patients is like
i come home
and i want things
now
are you adhd you know i'm one thing
right right now like i want an apartment
i want a house whatever it is i want
i want that and
when it comes to like working
having to wait for a paycheck things
like that i don't know anything about
that
you know i was just used to this
everything i'd ever done
was right then there cash money right
there
you know i call them cell phones credit
card i don't know nothing about none of
this stuff
were you treated differently than your
siblings
yeah
yes
in what way i was bored to death i was
the last one at home
and
i did what i want to do as far as like
i was in school but
no i had no um
supervision my mom worked my followers
and i was always by myself
i just came you know i can't even win as
i want to on my own and um i never had
to
really
answer after anything and whatever i
wanted i get and i had a grandmother
with my father's mother
if i wanted something and i tell my
father i wanted he wouldn't get it for
me i tell my grandmother and she'd make
him go by for me and she would tell me
if he don't get it i'll get it for him i
was 16 years old
and i never forget this and i wanted a
car so my father and i got me a 76
thunderbird
right and i had that car like a month
and a half i wanted a motorcycle
and i wanted a motorcycle and i told him
i wanted a motorcycle he said i just
bought your car i'm not getting your
motorcycle i went to my grandmother
two weeks later i had a motorcycle
sitting in the front yard
you know things like that i kept that
motorcycle for [ __ ] a month and i
never forget that i sold it for 25
automatic and 200 in cash
yeah when did your dishonest behavior
first start showing itself
teenager
no younger i would say
i stole money out i don't remember this
person
i was like 89 years old
i'm
yeah i was really really young without a
lesson now i stole money out of her
first i don't know what made me do it
where it come from
i just did it and it was always
to the point where like i was that guy
in school because i had money i don't
have money in my pocket i'm buying girls
all the candy and stuff like you know
you know i'm buying all the candy all
the treats and stuff like that i was
good they're generous i'm the one that's
always looking off
at you know they always look up to me
because i always have money you carry
around a lot of subconscious guilt yes
yes yes
yes does everything everything you
you have you kind of
got it dishonestly
honestly i have been and trying to think
i haven't
really had nothing in my life that i've
gotten honest honestly
everything i've ever done was has been
dishonest
everything
and
true story i met a guy i get out of
prison
and they have a program called
emerging leaders
it's emerging leadership academy out of
um
and the guy that started is um
he's an ex-cop but he's a sheriff
and he started this program for people
coming out of prison so we would sit
down one day and it just struck me one
day i'm sitting at a denny's restaurant
with this cop
eating breakfast with me and i'm talking
to him just like i'm talking to we just
and
i said
damn if you would have told me five
years ago i would be sitting in a
restaurant
with the you know
a sergeant from the sheriff's department
and enjoying and actually liking
it just messed me up and he turned out
to be a real good guy he's um
i can't remember his name um see that's
another thing with fentanyl it [ __ ]
your head it's like your memory
everything is just
where do you stay now are you on the
street yeah on the streets wherever like
last wherever i sleep wherever i can
yeah yeah you look pretty clean for
somebody who's
totally homeless
well we try to they have right down the
street that's why
they have the refreshment center i go
shower and stuff every day you get a
shower shave you
you wash your clothes and stuff like
that and so i'll try to you can look
pretty respectable it's a little saying
like i'm homeless but not hopeless i try
to
keep my appearance but you still have
hope of maybe walking a straight line
one day yeah
i really do
i really do but we changed your
behavior um
a job and a place to stay
if i if i
settle down and just get a roof on my
head i think it'd be a lot different
because like right now i don't even
enjoy getting i
honestly i do not enjoy getting out
anymore
but getting high now is just it's the
coping mechanism on the streets
it's the way i deal with how
some of the things i'm going through now
because i couldn't do it sober to be
honest
i'd go i see what drives a lot of people
crazy out here i would actually go nuts
if i was just have to do all this over
and
yeah
yeah
i
i do have hopes of
okay you asked your question earlier
what am i afraid of and i told you
myself and
one of the things i am afraid of going
back to jail
i do not want to die in prison i honest
god i did not want to die in prison and
i don't know where i came from but i do
not want to die in prison so yeah i have
to walk a straight line yeah exactly and
it's just that's always in the back of
my head now
you know i do not want to i don't know
what
that where that's from or what it is but
i do not want to die in jail
[Music]
and
like i said i'll be 63 in december and
uh yeah
and that's keeping me out right now
because like right now
i have no i have no
how do you make money now how do you
support yourself now
whatever
like
yeah and what i mean by there's just a
little drugs dealing here and there
stealing whatever whatever it takes um
i've been lucky lately i have and like
even this morning i got i can't came
across some kind of luck got lucky
guy i know came up and gave me a whole
bag full of
we just
big ass bag we just little things like
that and just
yeah but uh i'm
doing things against the law but it's
very
it's
pettiness compared to things that i was
doing and there's nothing to like really
put me in jail for any length of time or
anything like that plus
the laws out here in law saying it's a
joke now right they are they're a joke
now drugs and all that i've gotten hired
right in front of a cop
the other night we were sitting there
supposed i i got you i smoked some fat
synthetic in front of a cop there's
something illegal going on in every tent
no no no the cop driver we're sitting at
a bus stop and cop drives up me and the
girl's sitting there he dries up and i
got a pipe in my mouth
and he looks at me says um what do you
tell he says um
oh he says what is the cracker uh meth
all right i said matthew says good
choice and just drove off
and just drove away john what would you
say is the most important lesson you've
learned in your life
most important lesson is
[Music]
don't listen to yourself to myself
because what i mean by that is see i'm
my best friend but i'm also my worst
enemy
and
i need to start trusting
myself more
to the good things instead of all the
bad things
and
the most important lesson in life is
to me is i don't trust others
i hate myself but i trust myself more
i don't trust people
if it makes any sense i don't i i
because it's like everyone i ever and
it's
i'm i'm learning now that that is a lie
that i've been telling myself
i've always said that
i've always blamed others for my
mistakes
if it makes sense like i i used any
excuse
to go and do something wrong and i would
say oh mark made me do this the only
reason i want to rob this bank is you
pissed me off i needed some money you
wouldn't owe me 20 i needed to go get
high so [ __ ] it i'm gonna go out and
rob something and i would always use
that for excuses now i'm learning
i've been through [ __ ] my whole life
you know and
i'm at the point where i quit blaming
others for my mistakes i'm i'm learning
to accept
things that i've actually done
you know i've always i've always liked
i've always blamed other people
for whatever
and it's um
majority of the time they're right and
i'm dead wrong
and i'm just now learning to admit
that i'm wrong and i was like you know i
consider myself a con man at one time
because like i was running around
getting high and no one ever even knew i
was getting high
they would never
suspect i was that little drug addict
and
you know um
for years and years i get people now
tell me yeah you don't look like a bank
robber you don't look like you did that
and i've always used that as an excuse
to um
get over on people you know i've been a
user all my life
and not a necessary journalism i mean
user of people of just everything i've
always used
and
yeah i'm learning now that um
i've heard a lot of people bro
i have
but i don't feel bad about it and start
that's what i don't understand why i
don't have that you have no remorse
at all
at all
and i can't understand why
and i've talked to you know i've
actually talked to sykes about this and
they're telling me oh it'll come it'll
come here to come
it hasn't come in 63 years when's it
going to
come do i want to change you i honestly
got i do want to change
and we'll see hopefully i'll make it
this time
all right john thank you so much for
sharing your story no problem
you